zurück nach singapur in den urbanen
dschungel der durchaus nicht nur aus
beton besteht
hier tragen auch die hochhäuser mit
ihrer bepflanzung zu einem besseren
stadtklima bei und liefern damit ein
beispiel für nachhaltiges bauen
morgens um 6 uhr unterwegs mit den eth
forschern des future cities
wir besuchen eine überbauung namen sky
will heim für 3000 menschen erbaut 2015
auf verschiedenen stockwerken befinden
sich gärten dieser hier auf dem achten
stock ist eine oase für vögel
der biologe richard berger hat ihr
vorkommen untersucht wir fanden heraus
dass solche dachgärten einen positiven
effekt auf das vorkommen einheimischer
vogelarten haben bei den eingewanderten
haben gab es keinen unterschied
doch wichtig sind für die artenvielfalt
die einheimischen erhalten für die dies
dachgärten tatsächlich zufluchtsorte
geworden sind von den grünflächen
profitieren längst nicht nur die vögel
sie erfüllen auch andere wichtige
funktion
[Musik]
die grünflächen sind aufenthaltsort für
menschen bäume spenden schatten und
sorgen für kühlung
das ist eine der wichtigsten funktionen
der städtischen grünfläche sie können
die stadt im gegensatz zu den gebäuden
geben betont die hitze speichern und sie
dann während der kühlen nacht an die
umgebung abgeben
man nennt das phänomen auch den hitze
insel effekt städte heizen sich stark
auf weil die gebäude hitze abstrahlen
eine hitze die paradoxerweise auch von
den zahlreichen klimaanlagen mit
produziert wird
der grüne als natürliches kühlmittel das
hotel jr
für den diesjährigen internationalen
hochhaus preis nominiert ist ein
paradebeispiel für nachhaltigkeit die
großen innenhöfe sorgen für natürliche
belüftung
wasser überall auch dies hat einen
kühlenden effekt
zudem entstehen stimmungsvolle
gemeinschafts zone 21 verschiedene
schlingpflanzen wachsen an der fassade
für die vögel futter und lebensraum die
artenvielfalt hat in dieser stadt gegend
markant zugenommen
ein immenser aufwand wird in den
unterhalt gesteckt doch dieser hohe
preis scheint sich zu lohnen
lohnt sich die forschung die die eta in
singapur im future cities la betreibt
auch für die schweiz
was kann die schweiz von singapur lernen
ganz vieles ist sich sascha menz sicher
ihre der schweiz ihr werdet nicht
weniger eine weitere stelle fest dass
ein positives klima verantwortlich
handeln extrem warme sommer kdh also all
die effekt wo vor der auswahl dieses
wohne und dieses leben und arbeiten mit
hier wirklich im bereich von da über
neue und items in lernen wie mir
vielleicht auch in zukunft in der
schweiz die gebäude neu planen werden
und neubau uhrwerk